the town of veronika is one of the
loveliest on the island of Kirk
tomislav appendage is a chef at konoba
Lewton a local restaurant many of the
guests are tourists day-trippers eager
to savor the local cuisine
we have many dishes on our menu but our
meat dishes like Shiva Chi Chi and ples
covet say are especially popular with
tourists but we also have plenty of
guests who are open to new dishes and
who want to try our local specialties
besides tourism farming is a mainstay of
the local economy and almost every
family owns a small flock of sheep lamb
dishes typical for this part of the
Balkans are very popular at Kona Berluti
Tommy's la vía punch each likes to serve
goulash with homemade pasta called
Charlotte's in Croatian first mixed
together flour eggs and oil with a mix
hot water makes the dough nice and
smooth then knead the dough and allow it
to sit for 15 minutes
in the meantime chop the onions and cube
the meat the goulash can be made with
lamb mutton beef veal or pork saute the
onions and add tomato paste season with
salt pepper bay leaves and rosemary then
browned meat
zeliha mono then it's quenched with a
dry red red wine ads both color and
flavor after the alcohol is boiled off
add some warm water and bring to a
simmer then it's time to roll out the
pasta dough and cut it into equal sized
portions using your hands and a knitting
needle roll the dough carefully remove
the needle so there's a hole in the
middle because that way the pasta can
soak up the sauce that makes it even
tastier for the perfect accompaniment
round it all off with a glass of Sheila
Tina a dry white local wine
you